[Applause]
and finally new rule everybody should be
allowed to let themselves go a couple of
times a year
like now the dog days of summer school's
out rules out it's hot vacation time no
one should have to diet on vacation and
the holidays that's the other okay i'll
let myself go time of year and who can
blame us it's the end of the year
it's structured around feast days
no one should feel bad about opening up
the pants after thanksgiving dinner and
doing that thing where you undo the top
button and try to hold it together with
just the belt
that's all fine
but not all year round
and that's what's kind of happened to
america letting ourselves go now as an
all-year-round thing doing the
thanksgiving pants thing every day
they actually sell a business suit now
with drawstring pants
i saw this
i swear i saw this in the mall and i
said to the salesman this is pathetic it
shows how much we've given up and he
said no people love it
of course they love it you can have a
mongoose for lunch and then
give that big
presentation there's a disturbing trend
going on in america these days rewriting
science
to fit ideology or just to fit what you
want reality to be
we've gone from fat acceptance to fat
celebration
that's new
that is new
to view letting yourself go as a point
of pride
we used to at least try and be fit and
healthy and society praised those who
succeeded now the term body positivity
is used to mean
i'm perfect the way i am because i'm me
it's orwellian how often positivity is
used to describe what's not healthy
of course you can get away with anything
bad for you when you're young but let me
ask you this have you ever seen a fat 90
year old
scary isn't it
healthy at any weight
is an unchallenged lie
that people tell themselves or they can
go on eating whatever they want which is
fine
i've done many self-destructive things
too but no one pretended there was
positivity in smoking
fat activist ted kyle founder of
conscient health says the media and
public needs to stop catastrophizing
obesity
okay a they're not catastrophizing it
and b they should be
because it's a full-blown catastrophe
poor diet is the leading cause of
mortality in the united states
new york times
of course we're talking about heart
disease and cancer and diabetes but also
as covett has taught us obesity is
horrible for the immune system which is
why those numbers
were off the charts during the pandemic
that's a catastrophe
it's literally a national security issue
now military recruitment is down by the
most since the end of the draft because
mainly 17 to 24 year olds are too fat to
fight
at some point
acceptance becomes enabling
and if you're in any way participating
in this joyful celebration of gluttony
that goes on now
you have blood on your hands
full stop
you can make believe you're fighting
some great social justice battle for a
besieged minority but what you're really
doing is enabling addicts
which i thought we decided was bad
it's not just the drawstring business
suits companies like nike
sports illustrated victoria's secret
companies that are specifically about
fitness
nevertheless promote people who are
plainly not into fitness
people like adele
face shame campaigns for losing weight
this is madness
there's a reason the first thing your
doctor does is make you step on a scale
well
it used to be
there's a card now that you can give
your doctor and it says please don't
weigh me unless it's really medically
necessary
it's always necessary
it's like asking your dentist not to
look at your teeth
there's a popular t-shirt
that says i don't owe no man a flat
stomach
okay no one said you did
you do you
but you're not a freedom fighter because
you want to keep eating donuts
usa today actually wrote the sentence
science hasn't yet figured out how to
solve obesity
[Laughter]
and ted kyle concurs saying we don't
know how to blunt the rise in obesity
because we don't know precisely what the
factors are that are causing it
yes what could it be what's what
damn it this is a hard one
people say to me oh come on bill people
struggle with this of course they do
everything's a struggle life's a
struggle but somehow 50 years ago this
country looked entirely different you
don't think it was a struggle for them
you think cake wasn't delicious in 1969
and that's the saddest part we can do
this
i think but by lying about it and making
excuses psychologically it's telling
ourselves that letting ourselves go is
the best we can do and i gotta believe
that as americans we can still do better
than
[Applause]
you